welcome back to pearson organization
pride month used to be about celebrating
gay rights and campaigns for equality
it's now more about ag campaigns
celebrating righteous brands in places
where equality often already exists from
burgers to banks machines to marines yes
bullets apparently are now gay everybody
wants to know it's okay to be gay which
of course it is
except of course where it's not big
brands love to signal their virtue in
english speaking countries where gay
rights have been hard-fought and
hard-earned but not so keen to do it in
the middle east for example where it's
often illegal and punishable by debt
they don't really care about lgbtq or
you the only pride a lot of these
corporations seem to have is in their
quarterly earnings report world
football's governing body fifa for
example is flying the rainbow flag in
his headquarters a few months before it
flies the game superstars to the world
cup in qatar where gay people are
flogged or killed
and it seems nobody's more keen to show
you there along for the pride than
professional sports teams whether the
players like it or not paris
saint-germain footballer idris a guy sat
at a recent game because the rest of his
team were wearing rainbow emblazoned
jerseys he's a muslim from senegal where
being gay can land you in jail and five
tampa bay raised players in america this
week refused to wear uniforms with lgbt
rainbow logos for pride month citing
their right to make a personal choice i
would argue they have that right it
should be a personal choice as should
all social or political gestures we
shouldn't be shaming or abusing any
sports people frankly who don't want to
participate in this kind of thing but
that's just my view joining me discuss
all this is bisexual activist and writer
lewis oakley along with wrestler fox
news contributor tyrus welcome to you
both so let me start with you lewis
here's my issue about this
i don't think anybody should be forced
to
signal their virtue if they don't wish
to and yet we're seeing more and more
pressure now being applied both by
sporting uh teams and associations we're
seeing it applied by social media the
court of public opinion to say if you
don't do this then you are a bigot and
you should be shamed what's your view
well yeah i i totally agree we shouldn't
force people to
to wear things and and support things
publicly that they don't support it's
fine obviously that comes down to well
if you're not going to take the knee if
you're not going to wear these laces
what does this say about you and i think
that's where we need to have why should
i say why should it say anything about
you for example there are currently
there are black footballers who don't
want to take the knee anymore they think
it's lost it's it's steam and impact
if they should be allowed to say i'm not
gonna do it why shouldn't the white
player without you making the
insinuation well it says something about
you if you don't well this is the thing
i don't think if you're not going to
take the new if you're not the way to
lace it means you're a bad person i just
think it means okay well there's a
conversation to be had there are many
reasons why someone would not want to
wear rainbow laces or wear or wear the
pride thing
but we have to ask why like what is it
is it that you you know hate the gays
you don't want to see them around or is
it that you you know you think it's woke
or mad whatever it is
but that's where the issue is because we
still have to come back to the reason
this is being done right the reason this
is being done is because we still don't
have any out premier league footballers
it's still
got that
stigma of homophobia in it and we're
just kind of saying look how can we kind
of make up for this this has
historically been
somewhere where gays were not wanted or
bisexuals were not wanted i think
there's a perfectly valid point taurus i
mean i think that i you know would be
completely supportive of a lot of these
issues but i don't like the pressure
that's now being applied
for example to these tampa bay rays
players this sort of outrage over their
disinclination to signal their virtue
for pride they should be allowed not to
if they don't want to shouldn't they
well they should and and to
what you need to you need we need to get
back to having two thoughts on one
subject
i think you can be completely supportive
of
gay pride month and not necessarily have
to wear a banner flag for it during
black history month the united states i
don't expect my white friends to
acknowledge my blackness every day but
at the same time
it's about equality when you receive
equality you can also say while i
respect you i difference their opinion
or i just choose for no other reason
then i don't want to celebrate it right
it doesn't mean you can't acknowledge it
it can't mean you can't appreciate it i
think the problem is whenever somebody
doesn't acknowledge it we allow the
mainstream media to think that there can
only be one way you're either you're
either pro-gay or you're not right
that's not true you can support it and i
think what the what the tampa bay
baseball player eloquently said was
although he he supports and he has no
issues with them his religious beliefs
are what they are and we have to respect
that just like if someone says listen i
don't think of mixing of the races is
something i want to do in my household
but i don't have anything against black
people as a whole this is my personal
choice i don't have to like it and i'm
probably not going to have lunch with
that guy but i can respect it we it's
about respect yeah i mean i remember
about it i actually had actually quite a
long uh debate actually with my sons all
in their 20s when it was the the black
square day on instagram where post
george floyd and black lives matter
protests it was a day when everyone was
supposed to have a black square as their
instagram post and that was all they
would post all day and i didn't go along
with it because i didn't really think it
would be that effective and i just
thought it was a bit of a sort of
pointless virtue signaling my sons got
quite annoyed about it with me and they
were under pressure from their friends
who'd seen i hadn't done it and that
just showed me really how insidious a
lot of this pressure can be peer
pressure social media pressure and
corporate pressure to do these kind of
things but i think it's a balance right
like it's it's about yeah you should not
feel pressured to do anything don't
support things you don't support
actually why why would you want to say
you support somebody if you don't right
but at the same time you're feeling a
little bit of pressure there
like
no i wasn't feeling it they were feeling
it and the point i was going to make
with tyrus was you know for example
fifa who are putting on the world cup
the soccer world cup
their statement actually said this on
twit on twitter last week to celebrate
uh pride month the fifa world cup qatar
2022 will be a celebration of unity and
diversity adjoining of people from all
walks of life regardless of race
ethnicity religion age disability sex
characteristic sexual orientation gender
identity and expression everyone will be
welcome and they followed up with
another statement about pride but the
problem with all this is they've sold
the world cup rights to the country of
qatar
where it is illegal to be gay
well and that's the that's the same
problem that every group that's
recognized has nobody is more important
or more powerful than that mighty dollar
and that dollar makes a lot of
corporations turn the other way and they
try to set up fights in other places for
us to let me take a perfect example and
i'm gonna i'm gonna take race and
sexuality out of a minute just people's
perceptions i uh mr morgan i saw you
this weekend on tv and you were there
with a great sharon osbourne and i was
so happy to see her back on tv again the
perception of her is horrible right but
i know from personal experience when i
was a bodyguard for snoop we shared the
same apartment building as her daughter
and me and four of the largest brothers
you've ever seen had to sit outside in
the sun literally every day in the june
because there wasn't enough room in in
snoop's apartment do you know who came
up literally every other day bringing us
water and food to the point without no
mrs osborne no more thank you no more no
more she it was night time it'd be
sometimes it'd be 12 o'clock at night
and she'd be walking asking if we wanted
or needing anything there was no cameras
on but the perception was one thing and
she didn't have to broadcast her support
and she didn't care what color we were
she just saw four big hungry hot men who
just happened to be black that she took
care of you know what tyler's with me
would be like so much one word
out to me i think the word hot has shown
out to me there and that's probably why
sharon was hovering around in a sense of
temperature
i mean i don't think you know she's into
artists so i don't think we we fit but
the point is it goes back to the same
thing you can have the same support and
i like i said i have no issue
whether best friend neighbor whatever i
have no issue i care more about how you
pay your bills and how you treat your
neighbors than what you do uh in your
bedroom what color you are i think i
don't necessarily have to shout it to
the moon i agree
i think you hit the net on the head
about its actions speak a lot louder to
me the virtually signally final point
with you louis like bmw for example
did their gay pride social media posts
last week but they didn't do it in on
their middle eastern twitter account and
nor did sephora cisco mercedes so they
were supportive of gay pride here but
they weren't going to be supportive of
it publicly in countries where it's
illegal to be gay that is what gets my
goat about a lot of this stuff well it's
total hypocrisy and you know it's easy
to for a rainbow flag on something in
this country isn't it
where where they really need to be
putting their effort in those countries
yeah so it would actually have been
brave of them to have done it there um
but yeah and you know what lgbt people
see through that i think so too yeah
it's it's ridiculous lewis great to see
you thank you very much
always great to talk to you
please come back soon love having you on
the show thank you very much